donc cela avec la revue de presse
internationale de l'ines phrase bonjour
à la une de la presse donc cette
décision de la russie de reconnaître
l'indépendance de ces régions
séparatistes pro russes dans l'est de
l'ukraine et et on commence par les
quotidiens russes tous les membres du
conseil de sécurité se sont prononcés en
faveur de l'indépendance de donetsk et
de lougansk d'après commerçante cette
annonce ouvre la voie à une entrée des
troupes russes dans les territoires
séparatistes du donbass à l'est de
l'ukraine
vladimir poutine reconnaît defacto
l'indépendance des républiques
populaires autoproclamée en 2014 selon
un politologue citée par vedomosti autre
quotidien russe le but de la manoeuvre
du kremlin serait de jouer sur les nerfs
de washington et de ses alliés et de les
forcer à faire pression sur le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky pour qu'il
respecte les accords de minsk sur les
territoires séparatistes pro-russes on
va continuer à lire des unes de la
presse on en cyrillique avec les
réactions en ukraine le presse
ukrainienne parcouru par courrier
international estime que l'annoncent du
kremlin est la suite logique des
événements de ces derniers jours qui
avait déjà montré sans ambiguïté je cite
que la partie russe n'était pas disposé
à la désescalade
le journal donne notamment affirme que
les agents et les marionnettes de la
russie je cite toujours reproduise le
scénario qui avait déjà été appliquée
avant la guerre en géorgie en 2008
de la même manière grossière c'est à
dire en se livrant à des provocations
sur le front et en organisant
l'évacuation de la population civile
vers la russie au nom d'une supposée est
imminente offensive
l'ukrainienne de grande échelle pour
d'autres quotidiens l'heure n'est plus
aux questions sur les intentions de
vladimir poutine une partie des
quotidiens semble prendre acte purement
et simplement de l'annnonce du kremlin à
l'image du financial times qui rappelle
l'incrédulité ces derniers jours
exprimées par de nombreux diplomates
dirigeants occidentaux face aux
briefings alarmistes des services de
renseignement américains l'opinion de
ces sceptiques et tant que les combats
resteront confinées à l'est de l'ukraine
que l'objectif de poutine est avant tout
de créer effectivement une pression
suffisante pour que le gouvernement
ukrainien s'effondre ou que les
occidentaux face d'importantes
concessions diplomatiques
sur ce terrain précisément beaucoup de
questions un sommet entre poutine et
bayonne at il encore la moindre chance
de voir le jour quid de la rencontre
prévue ce jeudi à genève entre les chefs
de la diplomatie russe et américain le
journal suisse le temps exprime sa
perplexité face au jeu de pression de
manipulation et de propagande 1 auquel
se livre aussi bien moscou et washington
mais d'après le new york times la
réplique occidentale elle est bien le
dépendra de l'ampleur de la tacc russe
oui je préfère peut-être voir juste
avant ces quotidiens pour lesquels
l'heure n'est plus aux questions sur les
intentions de vladimir poutine peut-on
encore éviter une guerre majeure en
europe pour deux gardiens de la question
est purement rhétorique puisque le
quotidien britannique affirme que la
russie avance vers une action militaire
majeure une intervention qui aura était
en germe depuis 15 ans depuis que
vladimir poutine aurait déclaré sa
guerre personnelle contre l'occident
dans son discours sur la conférence de
munich de 2007 sur la sécurité ou le
président russe dénonçait déjà l'une et
l'unilatéralisme des états unis le
patron du kremlin a accusé de poursuivre
l' escalade l'annoncent dire sinon la
fin du processus de passe sous la
médiation franco allemande selon le
quotidien belge le soir
vladimir poutine accusée de torpiller
les efforts de paix par le quotidien
français le figaro pour qui la décision
de reconnaître l'indépendance des
territoires d'ukrainiens pro-russe
résonne comme une déclaration de guerre
et c'est le même son de cloche en du
côté du frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
qui voit le président russe sur le
chemin de la guerre je cite personne ne
doit plus se faire d'illusion sur à qui
nous avons affaire au kremlin et les
européens doivent tout faire en faveur
de la dissuasion y compris nucléaire
assène le quotidien allemand qui vous
est arrivé l'heure des sanctions sévères
de l'ue contre la russie l'union
européenne prévient le journal doit
répondre immédiatement à vladimir
poutine ne pas le faire serait continuer
à l'encourager donc des sanctions
occidentales oui mais lesquelles le new
york times je lui dis qu'elles seront
proportionnées à la réponse de la dmr
potier en effet cette attaque
prendra-t-elle la forme d'une accorde
une incursion mines mineurs ou d'une
guerre éclair et massive le choix de
vladimir poutine va définir la réaction
de la communauté internationale d'après
le quotidien américain new york times
damien qui estime que ce qui est en
train de se passer est certes la guerre
de poutine mais que les états unis et
l'otan ont leur part de responsabilité
le seul endroit où se trouvait pour
comprendre cette guerre c'est d'être
dans la tête de vladimir poutine le
dirigeant russe le plus puissant et le
plus incontrôlée depuis staline cela
étant dit l'amérique n'est pas
entièrement innocente dans cette dans le
déclenchement de cet incendie écrit le
journal qui met en cause notamment
damien la décision irréfléchie je cite
des états unis un d'élargir le temps
après l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique
on s'attendait pas forcément à ce que
les choses évoluent dans ce sens là avec
un président aussi puissant que la
lumière poutine plusieurs quotidiens
occidentaux s'alarme du ton
particulièrement agressif de
l'allocution du président russe il avait
encore le discours décousu du président
russe de times semble interloqué par la
leçon d'histoire souvent bizarre qu'il a
livré hier l'ukraine moderne a été
entièrement créé par la russie plus
précisément la russie bolchevique et
communistes a déclaré poutine ajoutant
que vladimir lénine était l'auteur et
l'architecte jules ce type toujours de
l'ukraine des propos qui amène le
quotidien britannique à s'interroger sur
la santé mentale du dirigeant qui a
passé une grande partie de la pandémie
enfermé dans sa résidence de campagne ce
qui lui a dès lors d'ailleurs valu le
surnom en russie du dionne dans le
volume caire merci beaucoup et hélène
pour ses unes de la presse on se
retrouve tout à l'heure tous